The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So I just want
to go back through
class five, because it's
kind of foundational
for the ideas
that come up in this class.
So just very quickly, David Hart
taught us about the ideologies
behind US innovation.
And he takes a look at
really the 1920s ideology
around science and
technology policy.
And as we discussed, the
same debates are with us.
And the leading theologies,
we could call them,
are the associationalists,
which we would now
translate as public-private
collaborations,
versus conservative,
which, you know, there
is no federal governmental role
except in the national security
territory.
And then the national
security rationale,
which I would argue
is, do whatever
it takes to establish national
security based technologies.
These ideologies fit the US than
honestly fit other countries,
but they are a significant
part of the story
about how policy has evolved
in science and technology.
Then we had a long
dissertation on Alfred Loomis
and the beginning of
the Rad Lab at MIT,
which we argued was really
a foundational model for how
the US R&D system is
going to get organized.
So that's taking
place right here,
and Loomis really
designs a system
that teaches us a lot about how
we're going to organize R&D.
So flat, non-hierarchical, team
based, very cross disciplinary,
collaborative, keep R&D
out of uniform and out
of uniform bureaucracies.
Keep it out of
the civil service.
Create a kind of flat,
non-hierarchical system
that enables maximum
exchange of ideas.
Vannevar Bush at
the end of the war
writes The Endless
Frontier, and that's
the foundational
document for US R&D.
And what he's concerned
about at the end of the war
is salvaging some
federal role in science.
So the growth of
the federal role
in science in the course of
World War II was profound.
As I mentioned in
class five, MIT
receives 80 times
more federal funding
in the course of
World War II than it
does in all its previous
80 years of history.
And that story is not unique.
Other universities are having
comparable experiences.
So that's when the federally
funded research university
begins.
And that's, obviously,
a foundational model
in the US system.
Vannevar Bush wants
to salvage it.
So in the midst of a kind
of a huge rapid scale down
to the defense establishment at
the end of World War II where
everything is being canceled,
he works with Franklin Roosevelt
to keep a federal
government research
focus in basic research.
Peter Singer reminded
us of how productive
that system has been.
So his paper on 22
examples of federal R&D
that translated into
major technology sectors--
so Peter argues
that that basic R&D
model has, in fact,
yielded enormous technology
development.
That's not an easy
thing to trace.
Waht are the originating
scientific advances
in a 20 year project
towards technology advance,
or perhaps longer.
But Peter kind of did what we
called genealogical research
to figure out what the
core elements were.
But it's there.
So it's not that Vannevar Bush's
basic research model in itself
is bad or wrong.
But it's an important one.
And William Blanpied
told us the story of NSF.
So the second Vannevar
Bush story is--
story one is support
basic research.
Story two, how are you
going to organize science
in the federal government?
And his vision was there
was going to be one tent.
And science was going
to fit under one tent.
You wouldn't have a
multitude of agencies.
He was not successful in
pushing that argument, remember.
Because Harry Truman vetoed the
National Science Foundation law
that he proposed.
Because Vannevar Bush
wanted scientists alone
to control science and
left out a significant role
for the executive branch.
So it got vetoed.
And therefore, NSF didn't
really get stood up
for another five years.
So other agencies
pop up in the void.
So that, in turn, meant--
this kind of funny
accident of time
meant that the US was going
to have a very decentralized
system of a multitude
of agencies working
on science and research.
That's how it happened.
And Blanpied lays out
that debate for us.
We then looked at Donald Stokes
as the kind of closing reading
last week.
And Stokes's book,
Pasteur's Quadrant
is something of a classic in
the science policy literature.
And Stokes argues that Vannevar
Bush saddled the country
with a disconnected system.
All very well and good, but
he missed a crucial quadrant.
He missed the quadratic of
use-based fundamental research.
In other words, you have an idea
about what you want to achieve.
But you use basic
research to get there.
He argues that
Pasteur's quadrant--
because Pasteur is out to save
kids in France from bad milk,
he knows what he wants.
But he goes back and develops
microbiology to get there.
So Stokes's argument
is Vannevar Bush
focuses us on curiosity
driven basic research.
He missed use-based
basic research.
And that was a big
gap in the system.
So what that meant in
the US was that we would
be good at the basic research.
We would have a
disconnected system.
It would be hard to
do the implementation
stages to achieve the
technology advances here.
And we have seen
that again and again.
The US would often originate
the foundational technologies.
I was just working on
lithium ion batteries.
A lot of those early
advances came out of the US.
It was not commercialized here.
So Vannevar Bush, of course,
understood connected science,
because he created that in World
War II, a brilliantly connected
model.
I would argue that what
he was trying to do
was salvage what he could
at the end of the war.
But Stokes critiques
him essentially
argues that we got a
disconnected system out
of this.
And that was very problematic
for the ability of the US
to stand up subsequent follow
on technology advances.
And we've seen that
again and again.
So that's a look at some of
the foundational issues on how
we organize science
and R&D in our system.
And today, we're going to
take a really deep look
at what we could call the
valley of death problem.
In other words, it's
precisely this problem
that Stokes talked
about, the disconnect
between the research stage
and late stage development.
And we're going to--
the Branscomb and
Auerswald reading
will lay that valley
of death problem out.
And then we'll
talk about actually
how the US is actually
on the side running
all parallel universe of
much more connected defense
research.
It's a very different system.
So we have two very
different innovation systems
that the federal
government is supporting.
And we'll go through
those two models.
So who's got got Branscomb and
Auerswald, which of you three?
Matthew, you got it?
OK.
That's Lew Branscomb, a noted
professor at the Kennedy
School, now emeritus.
He was vice president and
chief scientist at IBM.
He was a director of NIST,
a noted physicist working
in the atomic molecular fields.
He won the National Science
Foundation's Vannevar Bush
award, appropriately enough,
which is its top award.
A remarkable and lovely and
wonderful guy, and a real kind
of statesperson of science who
used to help young kids like me
and help us learn the system.
And his colleague,
Phil Auerswald,
is now on his third
or fourth book,
and has gone into the
field of innovation policy
in a deep way, and
is a real contributor
in that field as well.
So Phil is a spokesman in
his own right at this point.
He teaches at George
Mason University,
which has a strong science
and technology policy group.
So those are our authors.
And let me just
go to the charts.
This is a chart that was used
in the House Science Committee.
And it wasn't-- the term,
valley of death, between, again,
research and later
stage development--
that wasn't a term that
Branscomb and Auerswald
invented.
It kind of came into
currency, however,
in the time period in
which they're writing.
And the idea here is--
it's a very simple one,
that you've got one
set of institutions
working on basic research.
You've got another set
of institutions working
on the later stage, applied
side, later stage development
in particular.
And there are very few bridging
mechanisms in our system
across this gap between the two.
So as we tried to understand
innovation 20 years ago,
this was the major
idea in the system.
And it comes right out
of Stokes's thinking.
We're seeing this.
And what's happening
at the time is
that Japan has created this
brilliant quality manufacturing
system.
It amounts to a real
innovation wave in itself.
The US misses it and
then loses leadership
on two huge industrial
sectors, autos
and consumer electronics as a
result of getting this wrong.
So this is another
chart of the same thing.
This is more of
a pipeline chart.
And arguably, Vannevar Bush
set up the pipeline model
where the federal
role was going to be
dump basic research into the
end of this innovation pipeline.
Mysterious things will occur.
Great products will
emerge at the end.
That's essentially the
organizational model
for US civilian R&D.
This is a way to
try and understand
what's going on
within that pipeline
and who the actors are that can
influence different stages, who
can do the bridging.
And what Branscomb and
Auerswald set out is--
there's basic research.
There's the proof of
concept invention stage.
Then there's
technology development.
Then you move on to product
development and production
and marketing.
And then helping at
these different stages
are different actors.
So the basic research
agency's here.
And maybe they'll help you get
to the proof of concept stage.
But they're not going
to reach beyond that.
But then angel investors,
sometimes corporate allies,
sometimes the small
business innovation research
program that we've
talked about--
that might help you
move from here to here.
Venture capital, they
point out, doesn't really
come to bear in this stage.
Venture capital, as we talked
about in the first class,
is really only interested in
supporting your technology
if it's only about two years
away from actual production.
So they're not
going to help you,
by and large, with the
exception of the biotech area,
bridge across this
kind of gap territory.
When you get to here, there's
corporate venture, and equity,
and commercial debt
that will help you.
But they argue that this
is the gap in the system.
But they also note,
it's not a pipeline.
It's much more complicated.
And in the end, they adopt
this phrase, a Darwinian sea
between a struggle
for life and a sea
of technical and
entrepreneurship risk.
Because things don't move
smoothly down the pipeline.
You'll get to proof
of concept stage
and realize you've
got to rethink it.
You go back here.
And then maybe you
get to here and then
you realize, well, I'm not
going to be able to get
to product development.
I've got to go back to there.
In other words, it's a much
more convoluted process
with a lot of iterations
and feedback in that system.
So they argue, in the
end, it's more like this.
The innovation and new
business on one side,
research and invention
on the other,
and this kind of struggle,
in a Darwinian sense,
going on between the two.
But frankly, a pipeline model
is much more convenient and easy
to understand, even
though we should all
know that it
overstates the model,
that it's really more
like a Darwinian sea.
And then they go through
what are the funding sources
and note, really pretty
limited funding sources
that are available
for that bridge
over the valley of death.
It's a pretty limited panoply.
So why don't we
leave that there.
And I'll turn it
over to you, Matthew.
AUDIENCE: I think the summary
was pretty comprehensive.
So I mean, most of the
questions that I had really
focused on that stage theory,
that early stage technology
development.
As you could say,
it's the Darwinian sea
or the valley of death.
And one of the questions
I wanted to ask here
was-- we saw a lot
previously about metrics
to measure how much we're
putting into basic research.
And then we also have all
the economic indicators
on the other side.
Right now, is there any
good way to measure just
how effective a country
is at actually translating
technologies that
are being developed
into commercialized products?
AUDIENCE: Could you
rephrase the question?
AUDIENCE: Sure, yeah.
So I mean, could you
imagine any good way to--
or any good metric to measure
just how effective-- or would
it even make sense to measure
how effective a country is
kind of traversing
that valley of death?
Because there's a lot
of metrics in terms
of just how much we're spending
on one side on basic research.
And then on the other side
you have economic indicators,
productivity.
AUDIENCE: Well,
one idea for that
could be the sheer number of
startups that are produced,
which was something that I
think one of the later readings
had mentioned.
Or you could just look at
the success rate of startups.
So how long does
it take for them
on average to foreclose, or just
to go bankrupt, or to just--
how many of them do so?
And how many of them are
able to actually produce
a viable product?
Et cetera.
You could measure something
along the lines of that.
AUDIENCE: Longevity
and percentage of--
make it through first
year, five year, 10 year.
AUDIENCE: And I think it
would be important also
to measure how
much of that value
you actually capture
as a country.
You have countries
like Israel where
you have tons and
tons of startups,
but they all end up
getting exported.
They don't stay in the country,
because all of the venture
financing is in the US.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: There's
another possible measure too,
Matthew.
It's probably on your list.
Patents.
And patents have to list
the scientific research
on which they draw.
So you can actually go
into the patent literature
and understand the
scientific advances
behind the patent application.
But of course, many patents
sit completely unused.
They go on the shelf.
So it's just-- the
total number of patents
doesn't necessarily
tell you much.
AUDIENCE: Look at the
citations on the patents--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
but it does tell you
what the early stage research
was, often, that's behind them.
And look, the amount
of early stage research
that's being cited in
patent applications
has been growing profoundly.
So we know that some
of this research
is getting out of the left
hand side of the pipeline
out the end of it.
So it's important
from that perspective.
Other indicators?
AUDIENCE: I think
there's also something
to say for maybe the
economic impact per capita.
Really assessing, how
much does the innovation
end up impacting the
country's well-being?
And how do individuals--
whether or not
individuals benefit from it who
are regular citizens, rather
than just the industry
capturing that profit.
I think there's something to
be said about establishing
a metric for impact as well
that's based specifically
on per capita or
per citizen in order
to make it sort of
comparable to other countries
and the resources that they
have available to them or not.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
non-monetary results.
AUDIENCE: No, I think they
can be monetary results too.
I mean, the
regression analysis is
going to be more complicated.
But I feel like if you do
measures of well-being,
both on economic impact
and also on well-being sort
of statistical measurements
on, say, like--
I mean, I know people
measure happiness now.
That could be a really
interesting impact.
And I know that
you could do that--
for example, when we need
biotech, the people who you're
impacting, do they
feel like their lives
any better as a result
of your invention,
in addition to the economic
benefits of your advance.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I would say no.
I think it was
polio, that somebody
discovered it, and then
just kind of gave it away.
So that has a big impact.
You make a lot of money, but it
was important to [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
The issue here
is that often that
social impact is
going to take a very long
time to evolve at scale.
So if you're willing to take
a long-term look to reach
a level of a
reasonable assessment,
it's going to be a
very extended period.
AUDIENCE: It's such
a difficult metric.
AUDIENCE: What metric do you
have for measuring it, too?
Because you can say, oh, I
have x amount of Apple stock,
and I've made x
amount of dollars.
And that's improved my
assets over this many years.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well, you're
driving at its societal impact,
right?
AUDIENCE: But then
how do you measure--
AUDIENCE: But it could
also be specifically
in technical advances.
Like I wouldn't say
necessarily, from an investment
standpoint, that I
would care so much
about the happiness of the
stakeholder or the shareholder,
specifically.
AUDIENCE: But I
was going to go on
to say, how do I
measure how much this
has improved my
life, when you get
into issues with measurement.
It's complicated.
AUDIENCE: When it
comes to a measurement,
like you can have the best
invention, but you don't win.
You know what I mean?
Like you can come up with
something that's really great,
but if you're not a great
executioner-- like for Fitbit,
I met the guy who now
works for Google X,
and he created the
Fitbit, but way better
and had way more customers.
But because he didn't
raise a round of funding
before the economic
collapse, the product
never got to market.
So it might just
be chance, right?
So Darwinian sea
is a good example.
Your research can
be really good.
It can be really compelling.
You can be a great team.
But there's a lot
of other factors
that we don't take into account,
a lot of hidden variables.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: How about
another question, Matthew?
MATTHEW: Yeah,
actually one thing
that kind of a lot of
people caught on to was--
so Branscomb and Auerswald, they
detail three main challenges
to crossing the Valley of Death.
And the three challenges were
motivation on the R&D side,
to reducing that to practice,
trust between the technologist
and the business manager.
And then the third
is the sources
of funding for entrepreneurs.
And focusing in on that
trust or understanding even
between the technologist
and the business manager,
someone asked, is there
value in maybe changing
the way we educate
people, or having
more joint technology
in business degrees
or courses of study to
help bridge that gap?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Matthew,
I can give you a hint.
You can ask the person who
wrote the question to respond.
MATTHEW: He's double major, or--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No,
which one of the students
who wrote the question
that you're drawing on,
you can call on them.
AUDIENCE: It was a lot at once.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It was you?
AUDIENCE: So if you have
an answer, just like,
it was a lot at once.
MATTHEW: Yeah, so what do
you think the value would
be in maybe restructuring
the way we do education
or offering more
interdisciplinary
degrees in maybe, say, science
or engineering and business
to help bridge that gap?
AUDIENCE: I would look into
the top most successful
technologists right now.
So like Zuckerberg was
psychology and computer
science.
I think Larry Ellison,
he was medicine,
but then he switched and
then went to Silicon Valley.
Elon Musk was
economics and physics.
So I don't know if
that's a good answer.
AUDIENCE: So frankly, I'd
say you're in support of it,
because a lot of these
people that were successful.
Of course, correlation
does not imply causation.
So just because Mark
Zuckerberg happened
to use computer
science and psychology,
it doesn't mean that--
AUDIENCE: But I was
trying to-- the education,
in terms, like, has there
a bit a really, really
great technologist who was just
pure science, or like just one?
AUDIENCE: Maybe 100 years ago.
AUDIENCE: I think during
the transistor era,
there was a lot of
great technologists
that could execute well,
like Bardeen, Shockley.
And then that's
where Intel started.
AUDIENCE: Well, I don't
know about Shockley.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, he
didn't take the credit,
but he was still there.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
that's next week's story,
or two weeks from now story.
No, next week-- right, sorry.
Luyao, you asked that question?
So do you want to oppose?
Do you want to give us an
answer or your thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Like to me, I
realize the American system
is more flexible and
allows you to take
cross-disciplinary course.
But from my home
university, like
England has really
kind of narrowed
choices for each student.
So you see less students
choose a double degree
or double major courses.
I do think that plays
an important role
in the development of
innovations in the States.
This is a cross-country
comparison.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
As you all know,
there's lots of MIT
students who are
doing business minors and
engineering or science degrees,
and lots of
entrepreneurship courses
that people from both
sides are taking.
So I think it's a development
that's starting to occur.
Matthew, do you have a
closing thought on Branscomb
and Auerswald for us?
MATTHEW: I can give a personal--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Please.
MATTHEW: I actually am
a mechanical engineering
and business minor.
And I do think it's
really valuable.
At the same time, I
think specialization
is important to
keep, because I know
I'll never take as in-depth
mechanical engineering classes
as people who are
just that studying
that throughout their
four years here.
But I do think
having more people
with interdisciplinary degrees
can help transition that gap.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Great, thank you.
All right, so we're going to
push along to our next reading
here.
And Vernon Ruttan is another one
of our great growth economists.
Ruttan taught at the
University of Minnesota.
And he really develops the whole
concept of induced innovation.
In other words, how
does industry innovate,
is really the problem
he's looking at.
Obviously, it's not just
government agencies for sure.
Industry does the great
bulk of the innovation.
So he studies induced innovation
through his whole career,
and develops a whole set of
thinking about that doctrine.
And then towards
the end of his life,
because he dies only a couple of
years after writing this book,
he goes back and looks at the
Defense Innovation system.
So he's looking at
where these big strands
of the American economy come
from, things like aviation,
space, electronics, nuclear
power, computing, the internet.
And I wouldn't say
he stumbles, but he
focuses on the Defense
Innovation system,
and starts to lay out
for us what that's like.
So we've just talked about the
Vannevar Bush basic research
only, peer-reviewed,
basic science agency
model that we tend to
think of when we think
about US R&D. That's
the dominant model,
certainly on the civilian side.
But then there's this
whole parallel universe
that's organized in
a very different way.
And he goes back and
traces the history,
and has this very
provocative title--
Is War Necessary
for Economic Growth?
Because the big innovation
waves of the latter part
of the 20th century,
frankly, came out
of that Defense
Innovation system.
Those are the big ways
that I just listed.
So what's going on here?
And Ruttan tells a very
interesting story that--
this didn't happen yesterday.
He tells the story
of the development
of interchangeable machine-made
parts, which, as you all know,
is the core initial step
towards mass production.
And that gets developed
in the United States.
And how does it get developed?
It gets developed by
the War Department.
And the War Department
is, essentially--
you think of the
early 19th century,
muskets are made by hand.
They're made by blacksmiths.
Armorers they were called.
And every army had to bring
along a whole group of armorers
to constantly keep
its muskets repaired.
And every time a part
would break down,
they'd have to make a new part.
So they'd have to pull out
their forge and their anvils
and their hammers, and then
model that part exactly
so it would actually fit.
Because no two
parts were the same.
They were not interchangeable.
So Eli Whitney has a vision for
interchangeable machine-made
parts.
Why Eli Whitney?
You've heard of the
cotton gin, of course,
one of the key early 19th
century simple machines
that launched the industrial
economy in the United States.
But Whitney's got a big
problem with the cotton gin.
Anybody can make one.
You can see this thing,
and any decent mechanic
all over the country could
essentially replicate it.
So he's faced with
massive patent violations.
And he's handling lawsuits
all over the country.
He can't manage this.
So he has this
remarkable invention,
but he can't capture
any revenue off it.
So being a good US
industrialist, what do you do?
The War Department bailout,
that's what you do, right?
So he goes to his friends
and colleagues in the War
Department and
paints this vision.
Why make muskets by hand?
I'll give you interchangeable
machine-made parts.
We'll drive the costs
through the floor.
And you won't have to have
these armor trains dragging down
the speed of your armies.
We'll just have a bunch
of parts in boxes.
And you'll just snap them in,
and they'll be interchangeable.
It's a wonderful vision, and he
sells it to the War Department.
And guess what?
He gets something
that's the equivalent
of a cost-plus contract,
every industrialist's dream.
Whatever you need
to spend, spend it.
It's consistent with
our contract terms.
So he turns his factory in North
Haven, Connecticut, just north
of New Haven, into
an attempt to develop
interchangeable
machine-made parts.
He doesn't quite get there.
This requires really creating
the whole first generation
of machine tools.
And he isn't quite
able to pull it off.
You have a whole new way
of organizing the workforce
around division of labor and
around specific differentiated
tasks for the workforce.
So it carries all kinds of
organizational implications
with it, so that each
part of the labor force
is mastering one set of tasks
related to a production system.
All these things are
starting to happen
in that North Haven
facility of his.
And there's now a
museum setting that's
around this, so you can go tramp
the sites where all this was
happening in North Haven.
But he doesn't
quite pull it off.
But meanwhile,
there's two armories,
one in Harpers
Ferry, West Virginia,
and the other in
Springfield, Massachusetts.
And these armories are
pursuing the same project,
because it's so key
to the War Department.
It's an absolutely critical
technology capability
the War Department needs.
And the story that
Ruttan picks up
is the story of John Hall, who
runs the Harpers Ferry arsenal.
And over an extended period of
time, over many, many years,
he eventually perfects
the machine tools
that will enable the creation
of these interchangeable
machine-made parts.
And it's a remarkable story.
And only the long-term
patience and capital
of a government agency
is going to tolerate
this kind of 20-year project.
Interesting, the
minute he gets it done,
other industrialists understand
what the accomplishment is.
So Congress forces
Hall and the Army
to throw the patent
essentially into the commons
and be accessible to others.
So that stands up the whole
early industrial economy
of New England, building
these simple machines.
So you can go to
Connecticut towns,
Massachusetts towns,
which are blessed
with fairly small,
slow-moving water power,
because that's the power source,
that moves fairly steadily.
It doesn't flood a lot.
This is an ideal region
for water-powered energy
do the building here
to power the mills.
AUDIENCE: So you said
John Hall goes and makes
the patents open to the public?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
the Congress force--
Congress passes legislation
that precludes the Army and Hall
from having the patents.
In effect, they make
them available to others.
That turns out to
be of great benefit,
because then this
interchangeable machine-made
parts model can get
picked up by everybody.
AUDIENCE: I guess it would be
a huge benefit of the country.
But then people like
John Hall, doesn't it
give them a pretty strong
incentive not to do something
like that?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes,
it would give someone
a pretty strong
incentive not to spend
20 years of their lives
working on this stuff, yes.
But of course, he is
working for the military.
So it's not as if he would
capitalize alone on this.
But overall, it's a positive.
And the power of those
New England companies
to get their
congressional delegation
to kind of take that
patent away and put it out,
it's an important
political lesson.
It was just too valuable
for the Army to own it.
So this creates the
Connecticut River Valley
of all these small,
simple machine industries.
Clocks are famous
in New England.
Muskets are famous up and down
the Connecticut River Valley.
All these kind of early fairly
simple machines get built here,
and that's the New England
industrial economy.
That is the first place
the US to really--
obviously textiles are
developing in parallel,
including in Massachusetts.
But this system of
other hard technologies
and simpler machines starts to
take off pretty explosively.
So the lesson here that
Ruttan is pointing us towards
is how the military can
operate and the private sector
can't operate.
The military is willing to take
a couple of decades-long effort
and spend whatever is needed to
get that technology perfected,
because they really need it.
Those risks are too
high and the cost
is too high for the
private sector to manage.
So that's his
underlying point here,
that the military is going
to be able to do things
that the civilian
sector is not going
to be able to do in the
technology standup process.
We skip time, right?
I always try to provide some
MIT material in the class.
And this is Whirlwind, right?
Mainframe computers had been
created by the late '40s,
early '50s.
So there are a number-- you
can number them on one hand,
but there's a number being
stood up around the country,
particularly coming out
of Mauchly and Eckert.
And the UNIVAC
generation machines
came out of the University
of Pennsylvania Engineering
School.
But MIT, of course, wants
to play in this game.
So Jay Forrester, a
great MIT technologist,
persuades the Navy to develop
a mainframe flight simulator.
Now, the problem with
having a flight simulator
is that it has to
operate in real-time.
So the other mainframes tended
to be gigantic calculators.
This thing is different.
And to operate in real-time,
you have to have memory.
And Forrester and one
of his graduate students
create the magnetic
core memory that's
part of this Whirlwind system.
Now, this is a time also
of Defense cutbacks.
So the Navy actually
pulls the contract
on the Whirlwind system.
But also at MIT is a
professor named George Valley.
And George Valley was a veteran
of the Rad Lab in World War II,
teaching at MIT.
And he comes to the realization
that the Soviet Union
has developed a bomber fleet
of sufficient long-range
that they could
undertake a first strike
with atomic weapons,
because they developed
the atomic bomb in 1949.
And there was nothing,
nothing standing in their way.
We would have no idea they were
coming until it was too late.
So Valley is an advisor
to the Air Force.
And he gets the Air
Force in particular
are really concerned
about this problem.
And boy, is it a real problem.
It's a real problem.
So Valley persuades
the Air Force
that they're going
to have to stand up
a whole new airborne
warning defense system.
What's he going to do?
It's an incredibly
complex network.
It's going to have to get stood
up all across, like, the Arctic
and out into the North
Atlantic on ships.
And there's going
to have to be planes
with radar systems flying.
And there's going to have
to be radar installations
all over northern Canada.
In effect, they're going to have
to build a radar interception
network.
And then these varying
messages are all
going to have to come
to a single place.
And you don't have
a lot of time here.
And the messages have got
to be understood, and then
transmitted to
decision-makers to make
a decision on what they do.
It's a really
complicated problem.
So Valley realizes, I'm
going to need a computer.
He's walking around MIT, where
else but the Infinite Corridor.
And he bumps into Forrester,
and discovers Forrester
is actually building a
big computer, Whirlwind.
And Valley says, we need it for
this new early warning defense
system.
And he enlists Forrester,
who's over here.
Because it's real-time
computing, it's different.
It's not just a big calculator.
Look at this lady
sitting in front
of a keyboard with
a cathode ray tube.
That's this.
That's this thing.
That's not a standard
mainframe from ENIAC or UNIVAC.
That's this thing, right?
That's what they stumble on to.
And look at this.
Here's an Air Force
corporal sitting in front
of the cathode ray tube.
Signaling is coming in.
You guessed it-- signals
across telephone lines.
So the radar signals are being
sent to a central location
across telephone lines.
He's got this kind
of gun in his hand.
It's like an electronic gun.
It's the mouse.
That's what it is.
You point on it,
you get a readout
of what the signal means.
So here it is, like
in the early '50s.
That's Whirlwind.
That's SAGE.
Lincoln Lab has to get created
to really drive the research,
because it's not just going
to happen in professors' labs
in MIT.
MIT starts to make these
computers, and decides,
we don't want to be in
the computer business.
So the contract is given to
IBM to make the computers.
And that becomes
IBM 700 series, it's
first really big important
set of computers.
So you begin to get an idea of
the ramifications of pursuing
this Defense
project at the scale
that the Air Force is
willing to pursue it at.
I'll just tell you
one more story.
At the end of World
War II, there's
two countries that are making
a lot of progress on computing.
The British have made
a lot of progress
at Bletchley Park on
computing, because they have
to cope with the U-boat threat.
And they have to decipher
these incredibly complex Enigma
signals that the German
communication system relies on.
It's really quite
capable cryptography.
And they develop computers
to be able to break
those signals down.
So the British are going well.
And they share a lot of that
information with the US,
and we develop comparable
encryption capability.
End of Wordl War II, Britain
dismantles its war machine,
cancels its nascent
computing operations.
There is one company in Britain
that picks up computing.
It's a tea biscuit company.
At 4 o'clock, everybody's
got to get tea.
And at 4 o'clock, everybody's
got to have fresh tea biscuits
right there in the tea shop.
It's a very complicated problem.
It involves incredibly complex
railroad time schedules
and analysis of delay
and delay factors.
And they need a
computer, so they
take the wartime computers the
British have been developing.
And they develop this
whole computing system
for getting tea biscuits
throughout the British Isles
at 4 o'clock in the afternoon
at all the tea shops.
That's one development project.
The other development project on
the other side of the Atlantic
is the United States Air Force.
They're beginning to
develop missile technology
and ballistic
missile technology.
And boy, does that
require computing.
Getting those trajectories
right really requires computing.
Who does the IT revolution,
the tea company or the US Air
Force?
Who wins?
You can only guess.
So that's how these
things happen.
There's often
foundational stories.
They're pretty key here.
But you get that
rough comparison
of what you're up against,
if you're the British tea
company trying to develop
computing versus the US Air
Force.
The US Air Force is
doing this stuff--
magnetic core memory, the
mouse, the cathode ray.
They're putting all
these pieces together
that become foundational.
The Whirlwind project
becomes the SAGE project.
And that becomes really
critical for a lot
of early computing, particularly
real-time computing.
The Defense Department
goes on to semiconductors.
It goes on with key work in
all kinds of semiconductor
technologies.
It goes on to
supercomputing, leading
that, all kinds of
advances in software.
When we talk about
DARPA, we'll talk
about the development
of personal computing
in the network and the internet.
But it's a powerful story of
this Defense Innovation system
and the role that it
plays in the US economy
in the second half
of the 20th century.
So which of you has got--
Matthew again, all right.
You're up.
MATTHEW: Yeahl so there are
definitely a lot of examples
that Ruttan gives.
And his thesis was that
maybe these technological
developments would have happened
anyway, but that urgency of war
made these happen a lot faster.
And you see the DOD
becoming, in his eyes,
the major organization
that's kind of funding
this technological development.
So I think the one
question we really
to need to ask is, is war
necessary for economic growth?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That would
be the foundational question
at the least.
That's a great question.
I mean, it's a great question.
AUDIENCE: Well, I have a
counter question to that.
Maybe rather than war,
maybe what's really required
is DOD funding.
Throughout a lot
of this, granted,
there was a lot of Cold War
paranoia that was fueling this.
And that was fueled
on all these advances.
But you could still paint
a lot of the problems that
face us today as
national security risks.
And then you could get a
similar level of urgency.
Even though we're
not technically
at a war with, say, the climate,
you can't really shoot that.
And you kind of need it to live.
So maybe it's less
about war and more just
a sense of priorities.
AUDIENCE: I think that's
a really good point.
Pretty much every
presidential campaign debate
I've ever watched,
there's always
the essential question they
ask, where they're like, oh,
what's the biggest
risk that you think
is facing our nation today.
And often one of the
answers is climate change.
So I think that might be a
really key part of rephrasing
or reorienting our
perspective to maybe start
re-allocating
funding towards what
is necessary for the welfare
of the nation that might not
always be another
nation's intentions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think he
used it as a provocative title.
But it should have
actually been called,
Is the Threat of War
Necessary for Economic Growth,
because I think there's a
stronger argument for that.
Yeah, threat makes us put
funding into national security
technologies.
Also we've talked a bit
about Japan's manufacturing
innovation.
And I don't think that
was spurred by war
or the threat of war.
So it's caveats.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, and
you make an important point
here, too.
Which is, the US is
pretty unique in putting
national security at the center
of its innovation system.
Other countries don't do that.
For sure, Japan doesn't.
For sure, Germany does
not at this stage.
So other countries have other
organizational motivations
than, as you put it,
the threat of war.
But it's a powerful
one in our country.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's the
other point I wanted to make,
is that I think Ruttan was
very United States-centric just
throughout our entire reading.
MATTHEW: So with that
in mind, is there
anything to worry
about the $54 billion
cut to science and
basic science research,
and reallocating that
towards national security
defense, if that's going
to go to the DOD anyway?
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess I could
get a job flipping burgers.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I
don't think the $54 billion
will necessarily go
into Defense R&D.
And obviously, the
entire $54 billion
didn't come out of the
domestic side either,
but there are very
significant cuts to US science
on the civilian side.
I don't think
they're going to be
offset by corresponding
increases on the defense side.
We should be so lucky.
But I think, Matthew, you're
driving an interesting point.
Suppose there's no war, right?
What's the motivator
we're going to use
to drive a technology advance?
MATTHEW: I think one person
mentioned in their question
if maybe international
competition could replace
kind of that sense of urgency.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
it's just a question of,
what are your priorities
at the current moment,
and what can you make
urgent enough just
to justify kind of large-scale,
huge, not just funding,
but reorganization around maybe
computers or key principles.
And so in this case, I guess
it was a threat of war.
But you could probably
argue, around the time of--
man, I'm forgetting.
But there's probably some
public health epidemic
that you could argue
that would have
spurred massive
bioresearch in that area.
And I think that can also
happen internationally.
So you think maybe
the development
of an epidemic in
a different country
could also spur bioresearch
in other countries
to supplement or help.
And so I think we could
even generalize even further
and just say, is threat
necessary for economic growth?
AUDIENCE: I think the
big point about war
is that you're a kind
of centralizing everyone
towards a common cause.
So I think a lot
of the initiatives
nowadays, like the Cancer
Moonshoot or even the push
around getting a drug
out there for CF,
like those targeted initiatives
towards a certain cause,
I think those could
be one way to target
the need for development
in a certain area,
in times of peace, where you
don't have a war impending.
AUDIENCE: One thing I
thought was interesting,
especially when people were
discussing the increase in DOD
funding, despite the fact
that we're not really
in a World War II era of
war, I've noticed that--
how much of MIT's
funding is DOD?
It's like half, right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No.
AUDIENCE: It's not.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Not close.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it might be just
the Nuclear department then,
which makes sense.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yes, that makes sense.
I don't know.
It's like in the 18% range
of federal research funding.
So NIH and DOD are just
about equal at MIT,
in terms of originating research
funding for the university.
MIT tends to be somewhat
higher in defense research
than most universities.
It's not close to half.
AUDIENCE: So the point
that I wanted to make,
though, regardless
of the exact number,
I'm sure that a lot of DOD
money is spent on things that
don't necessarily
have applications
of, say, building a better
tank or a better missile
or anything like that.
So just because some
things have the label
and are under the
Department of Defense,
that does not necessarily
mean that they're
going strictly toward learning
how to fight a new enemy.
I'm just curious what
your thoughts are.
AUDIENCE: Can you rephrase that?
AUDIENCE: OK.
So MIT, we don't really
research building
better guns and bombs, right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Correct.
And we don't do classified
research either.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So just because we have a lot
of DOD funding coming our way,
it does not necessarily
mean that we're
researching better
ways to kill people
or to keep ourselves
from being killed.
AUDIENCE: Does that funding
come to MIT the institute,
or Lincoln Lab as part of MIT?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So Lincoln Lab
is a separate entity
from MIT and, in fact,
undertakes a lot
of Defense work.
But it is defense, not offense,
is kind of a general rule
that they apply.
AUDIENCE: So that 18%
doesn't go to just MIT.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm not
counting Lincoln Lab in that.
AUDIENCE: So my thought
on that is basically just
that, you're taking this
money, but it's not necessarily
trying to make us a
better war machine.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So Max, in our reading
of Glenn Fong, which
I think comes next,
we're actually going to
derive after this exact point.
So we can really lay out
some of those nuances
when we look at his piece.
So Matthew, do
you have a closing
thought for us on Vernon Ruttan?
MATTHEW: I think I thought
very similarly to other people
here, that it seems
more than war itself.
A sense of urgency and
threat, whether it's
military or health-related,
that's really what drives us.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And that'll drive a
societal, scaled-up effort,
those kinds of concerns.
I think you're absolutely right.
AUDIENCE: My main
concern with this piece
was like, you're overspending
to move very quickly, which
isn't really great.
But also right after--
like once your initiative
is done, that's like
saying, yeah, I'm
going to diet up until
Friday, like right
after you kind of go all out.
So I wonder if these things,
if you move the science forward
very quickly, and then people
just kind of drop it after.
So there's this
kind of lost cause,
and they don't advance it.
Because also, like
for most technologies,
like we can't do
certain technologies
that we would have been
able to do 50 years ago,
because the experts in
that kind of thinking
are not here anymore.
AUDIENCE: I had a quick
operations question for Bill.
When it comes to increasing R&D
funding for agencies like DOD,
is it the Congresspeople
and Senators acting sort of
in an executive capacity
for their districts,
or is there pressure
from the district
to sort of increase the
policymaking for that,
in terms of national defense?
So I guess I'm asking, are
legislators acting autonomously
in defense of the
country, or is there
pressure coming from
their districts, as well?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So members of Congress
tend to be much more concerned
about defense spending that's
part of big
acquisition programs.
Who's going to get the next
award for the next Air Force
aircraft?
That's significant scale.
R&D spending tends to be at
a much more modest scale.
And Congress itself has
eliminated the appropriations
earmarking system.
So members can no
longer go into bills
and stick money in for
projects in their district.
That system has really
been significantly--
I wouldn't say it's
been eliminated,
but it's been
significantly reduced.
So the Congress itself, to some
extent, has reformed itself.
Now, the problem for that
is that it gives members
much less at the stake
in federal expenditures.
If they can't affect what's
going on in their own district,
why should they care what
federal appropriations levels
are?
So it's a two-edged sword here.
But by and large,
members of Congress
have stayed out of R&D. They
don't really touch DARPA.
They certainly don't touch NSF.
They don't touch NIH.
And part of this
is that the amount
of funding awards for a research
project are relatively modest
and really don't affect
anything at scale.
What they worry about are these
larger acquisition projects.
AUDIENCE: Was that also the
case for the [INAUDIBLE]
observation that
Ruttan undertook?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm
not sure I follow you.
AUDIENCE: Was it
the pre-earmark era?
Was it present
[INAUDIBLE] observation?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
The earmark era is only in it
in the last four or five years.
AUDIENCE: So then Ruttan was
operating under that system.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, but again, there
wasn't very much earmarking
of R&D funding, which
is really what--
he's focused on the
innovation system.
OK, so Glenn Fong--
and he starts his
piece with a quote
from a former White
House chief of staff,
John Sununu of New Hampshire,
who states, "We don't do
industrial policy," in the US.
And Glenn takes that line on and
essentially proves otherwise,
that we actually are operating,
at least through the defense
sector, with what can
only be viewed as a pretty
significant industrial policy.
So how does case studies
of various agencies.
It's not all defense.
He also looks at
Commerce and NIST.
But he concludes
that the significance
of the governmental role,
particularly on the defense
side, is really quite strong.
And that because of the volume
of the spending, in particular,
that's particularly powerful
on the defense side.
And he argues that there are
about four models to drive it.
The question, Max,
you were asking about,
there's about four
models by which
DOD undertakes its
spending that happen
to have spillover effects
into the civilian sector.
So one model is what he
calls the byproduct model.
Military R&D will have
unintended spillovers
into the commercial sector.
And he cites ARPA-NET
as an example of this.
In other words, when
DOD is setting up
the internet, the ARPA-NET,
for its own internal purposes,
it's a defense communication
system, and a communication
system between the early
computer science departments
that DARPA has been supporting.
It's a way for them to
communicate and transfer data
amongst themselves.
They're not
envisioning that this
is going to be the standard
form of communication
of the 21st century.
They were thinking about a
much more immediate problem.
But the byproduct
is that we create
this massive economic sector.
Then there's an
intentional spinoff model.
So commercial
spinoffs get expressly
contemplated during the
program planning around an R&D
initiative.
And [? E-side ?] strategic
computing and VHSIC as examples
where DARPA know that what
it was going to create
in the computing sector was
going to benefit all parts
of the computing
sector, not simply DOD.
But the gains were
significant enough for DOD
that it was really
important to pursue this.
And in fact, DARPA
and the IT revolution
in general consciously
worked on standing up
a lot of these technologies
in the civilian sector.
Why is that?
Because the Defense
Department is often
quite good at standing up the
early prototypes of a pretty
radical set of technologies.
But they don't have
the follow-on capital
that the civilian sector
can muster, a big financing
follow-on capability.
So DARPA consciously
understood this,
realized there was
going to have to be huge
incremental advances
in the technologies
it was standing up.
It would help create
the model, make
it available in the civilian
sector, on the assumption
that a rising IT sector and
financial support system
would come in and scale this up.
It would radically
drive the price down,
enabling DOD to buy
the technologies back
at a fraction of the cost and
with much greater capability
than their own system
would be able to do this.
So DARPA's decision to stand
up a lot of the IT revolution
around computing on
the civilian side
comes from a pretty
conscious effort
to understand the dynamics
of what was going to be.
And they all understood
it to be a very large
potential economic sector.
And how DOD could be
the initiator and then
leverage off what were going
to be much higher investments
on the civilian side.
So for example, for a
long period of time,
DOD would be the initial market.
So when we talked about how
Kilby and Noyce developed
the integrated circuit,
the core breakthrough
technology in semiconductors,
and really in computing,
the only customer for
the first four years
were the Defense
Department and NASA.
So the Defense Department
carried all those advances
through the first four years
of new generations of advances
for integrated circuits.
It wasn't until four years
later that a civilian sector
started to evolve.
So DOD can play this
initiator model.
And what Glenn Fong
is driving at here is,
that's an intentional spinoff
model that works well for DOD.
Also, DOD has an
explicit dual use model.
So a defense project could
have the explicit goal
of developing a
military technology
and a civilian
technology in parallel.
And advances in lithography
in semiconductor etching
are a pretty good
example of that.
High performance
computing, which Al Gore
helped to originate and pass
the original legislation before,
these were going to have
benefits on the military side
big-time, but obviously
corresponding big benefits
on the civilian side.
And then kind of the
fourth model, Glenn
points out, for how DOD thinks
about its role in the economy
and intervenes in
the economy and has,
in effect, an industrial
policy, is what he calls
the industrial base model.
So sometimes, DOD
is going to decide
that it must have an industrial
base in a particular sector,
and will consciously
support the development
of an industrial base
in the civilian sector.
The best example
of this I know of
is that both the
Navy and the Army,
in the early days of aviation
in the 1920s and '30s,
are consciously
attempting to create
a very strong civilian
industrial base in aviation.
Because they know how
powerful and important
that's going to be.
So Admiral Moffett, who
was leading the Navy's
early aviation program,
carefully makes
sure, in the
appropriations process,
the congressional
that there are a multitude of
projects for engine makers,
for airframe makers, for
different types of aircraft.
So that he's going
to start to stand up
a whole industrial
base and aviation.
It's done very consciously.
I think that's the best example.
But there are other
examples like that,
too including in the IT
side, such as Semitech.
When Japan came very close
to capturing leadership
in the semiconductor sector--
and we talked about this
in the manufacturing class--
DOD intervenes.
So under President Reagan,
DARPA jumps in here
and cost-shares the development
of new advanced manufacturing
approaches in semiconductors,
so that the US
could get back into that game.
Japan had figured out better
processes, better production
systems, more efficiency,
higher quality in semiconductor
fabrication.
The US had missed these.
This was a conscious
attempt to keep up,
because the Defense
Department felt
it had to have an industrial
base in semiconductors.
So these are four ways by which
DOD is willing to intervene.
It will not intervene
just for straight economic
competitiveness reasons.
So getting back to our
conversation earlier, Max,
it's not going to do
something just because it
will help US competitiveness.
It will only do
it if it can find
one of these very close military
needs associated with it.
And these are the
four models they use.
Who's got the Q&A
on this, Chris?
I think we're Through.
Yeah, we're through this.
Why don't you lead
us off in some Q&A.
And Max has got a question, too.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So as we just went
through pretty briefly,
he mentions a lot
of different models
and different
agency projects that
have been kind of case
studies of opportunities
that the DOD largely
has used to advance
technological innovation,
somewhat indirectly.
So maybe we could start
off by discussing,
which model do you guys
think is most effective?
Do you think it changes
when you consider
different industries
or different focuses?
And how applicable is this kind
of structure to present day?
AUDIENCE: I think what's really
cool about all these is they're
separated by intent, really.
So if you're intending to
have a sort of dual use--
it's probably easier to see the
bottom two than the first one.
But the dual use and
the intentional spinoff
are pretty strong arguments
for how DARPA projects could
be effective and useful and why
you should advocate for them.
It'd be pretty hard to
do the byproduct model
with that sort of
intent for spinoff,
just because you have
absolutely no idea of how
that's going to turn out.
But because they're
separated by intent,
I think it's pretty fair
to say that, depending
on what sort of project
you're looking at,
you're going to see which
model is going to be better.
And it's nice that you can
do that from the get-go.
When you start the
project, you can kind of
see where that's going.
AUDIENCE: So just personally,
it seems like some of these
might be hard to kind of create
a project around, oh, I'm
going to have
unintended spillovers
into the commercial sector.
In some sense to me,
it seems like a bit
like post-classification
of what has been done.
So thinking about
the DOD as they're
trying to fund projects,
what do you think
are their main
priorities, in terms
of potential commercialization
and potential kind of benefits
that way, and also benefiting
their military efforts?
What do you think
is that balance,
and what kind of
characteristics would they
be looking for in, maybe,
a funding proposal?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'd
say one characteristic
that they look for and
definitely emphasize
would be superiority
over other countries
who are working
in similar fields.
So with the semiconductor
thing, the moment they saw,
hey, Japan's doing this,
they're like, oh no.
OK, now we need to get on this.
What was the direct implication?
That was my
question, by the way.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Semiconductors?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [INAUDIBLE]
for the computing system.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because you said
the DOD does not
support different
industries unless it
has a direct national
security application.
So I guess I'm just
trying to figure out
how we could implement
these ideas today,
so that we could, I guess, boost
our current innovation system.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
it would be military-based,
but you just go
with a focus point,
have that kind of
military ideology of like,
we need to get here
by X amount of time.
And let's put these
efforts and try
to think more as
a system, rather
than different departments.
But you would put initiatives.
Like in private capital that's
been happening recently,
like [INAUDIBLE] made
a private initiative
to cancer and certain diseases.
But if you have a
national effort--
I don't know.
I wasn't alive during this,
but I think during the '70s,
during the Cold War, there
was a huge initiative
for science and rockets.
I don't know.
You probably know.
I haven't seen a
[INAUDIBLE] this.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We'll get
into that in a later reading
today.
AUDIENCE: But I think
definitely having
a strong national interest, but
not just financial incentives.
Because from a
management perspective,
people have different
ideas of what's good
and what they want out of life.
So I would do financial
incentives, social incentives,
in terms of, you solve this
problem, you're a superstar.
Kind of like an Einstein,
it'll get you on TV.
And then also educational,
in terms of like,
oh, these are our star
students, from five years old,
10 years old, 15 years old, so
they're part of the community.
And that's probably
how I'd do it.
And getting rid of
egos, like finding a way
to do that in a system, that's
how I would think about it.
But I'm interested in
what policy people think,
people who focus on policy.
I don't know policy.
Have there been policies in the
past that do something similar?
AUDIENCE: Well,
apparently, right?
AUDIENCE: I mean
outside of this.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Martin, you're
laying out a whole new set
of initiative drivers here.
And it's an interesting list.
And in fact, in the
Sputnik era, which
we'll talk about
a little bit, we
do see a tremendous
focus on education,
for example, and training,
and the importance
of being a scientist.
Those all come to the
forefront in American society
for a reasonable period of time.
AUDIENCE: And coming back
to what I was actually
saying, because it's
less obvious, or at least
it's not as advertised
to the American people,
that, in a lot of
aspects, we're not really
doing all that well, like
education or in manufacturing.
Because it's not
advertised as much,
perhaps that's
why maybe we spend
some time resting on our laurels
from the '70s or whatever.
And maybe that's why we're
progressing less quickly
in other places.
AUDIENCE: To bring in the
question you asked earlier,
Chris, I really like
the diagram, I guess,
he poses on page 161.
I guess I can zoom into it on my
computer, where he essentially
shows where each of
these fit on the models.
And I like this trend line was
in between intentional spinoff
and explicit dual use.
And I appreciate
that in particular,
because I think it
really highlights--
and even within the context
of him choosing those as case
studies--
a point that he had made
towards the beginning
on structural attributes
of the United States.
And he argues something
along the lines of,
structural attributes determine
industrial policymaking
capabilities.
And the US has deficiencies
in industrial policymaking,
because we don't care,
or rather because we
don't put an
emphasis on creating
that policy explicitly.
And I guess I question
how much of that
is, I guess, a cultural
barrier almost, that we have,
or a perception barrier, more
so than a policymaking barrier.
Because if policymakers
don't conceive of themselves
as change agents, maybe--
was there a reading in this
concept for this week that--
was it yours, Bill,
the fifth reading?
Yeah, that talked
about changing,
because if policymakers
don't see themselves
as change agents within
the economic context,
and they feel like that should
be left up to private markets,
then they might not feel like
it is their position or even
something in their
area of expertise
to promote industrial
policymaking
as a key to economic growth.
But if, I guess, someone
were to articulate--
or maybe, Bill, that was you.
Maybe that was your position
in the Senate, right?
If there was someone who
was clearly articulating
the link between
industrial policymaking
and economic growth as of the
utmost importance, then maybe
they would do it more often.
So I think that's where
that diagram that he draws
is really important in
establishing that trend
line between intentional
M off modeling
and the explicit dual use model.
Because it is perhaps
precisely trending
towards explicit dual
use that you can convince
policymakers to invest in
R&D, and not in basic research
and not explicitly at
the hands of the market.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Chris,
do you want to react?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That was a lot.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
No, go ahead, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no, go ahead.
I'm still trying to
gather my thoughts.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, no.
I'll say just a couple words,
then Rasheed and then, Chris.
Industrial policy is a negative
term in the United States.
And what it's come to suggest is
that the government is playing
a role, intervening
in the marketplace
to pick, as the phrase
goes, winners and losers--
in other words, who's going
to be the successful firms
and who's not.
And what Glenn is arguing
is, like it or not,
as the military moves into these
very applied areas in the IT
revolution, it is playing
an industrial policy,
industrial organizational
kind of role, like it or not.
And even though we deny we have
industrial policy in the United
States, Glenn is arguing,
look, as a practical matter,
the Defense
Department definitely
has tendencies in
this direction.
So this is a debate about pros
and cons of industrial policy.
I think Glenn is
arguing, you want
to see these
technologies stood up,
you're going to have to think
about how you're actually
organizing to implement them.
AUDIENCE: As a
quick followup, do
you think that he would argue
that calling it by its name
is important?
Rather than having these sort of
disambiguations about research
and development
funding, we really
talk about it in
an economic sense
as industrial policymaking.
And if we call it
like it is, then
perhaps we would sort
of destigmatize market
interventions, at
least in this context.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You're right.
We invent a lot of phrases
to not use that term.
For example, in the
civilian research side,
when the Advanced Technology
Program is being put together
that funds industry-applied
research projects,
the argument is, this is
not industrial policy.
We are funding
pre-competitive research,
which is going to land and
be accessible to a number
of firms.
So we're not particularly
picking one firm as opposed
to another.
We're funding pre-competitive
research that will benefit all.
And that's not a bad theory.
There are issues, as
Charles Shultze taught us,
about governmental intervention
and industrial policy.
This is not a simple landscape.
It's rife with problems.
We'll get to In-Q-Tel as
soon as we take a break.
But that's the ultimate
interventionist governmental
mechanism.
But Rashid, go ahead.
You had a point.
AUDIENCE: There are two
things that are separate.
I think one, very
quickly, is DARPA.
I think it was in
one of the readings.
They do actually, at each stage
of their project development,
they sort of kind of have you
hash out just a white paper,
identifying what would be the
potential commercial impacts
of this research if it
were to go to market.
So they have sort
of staged places
where they're
thinking about, how
are we going to
transition in toward
to this byproduct
intentional spinoff
in an explicit dual use.
Because they
realized like, yeah,
we're doing research,
that's great for us.
But obviously, this is going
to have benefits elsewhere.
But I think what's
important is DARPA actually
has stages where they
identify, and they
make you sort of write it out.
And it's not
punitive or binding.
But they say that
they're thinking about,
how are we going to actually
transition this defense
research into
commercial applications?
And that's really important.
Because they're kind of
speeding through a lot of steps
here in the R&D space, by
putting so much money in it,
doing these high risk,
high reward opportunities.
But they're thinking
actively about how
they're going to
benefit the consumer
and commercial efforts.
And then two, I
think policymakers
as change agents is pretty key.
And Martin and Steph kind
of hit on it a little bit.
But I think it's just a
different way of thinking.
And maybe it's just
calling it like it is.
Maybe it's just saying,
industrial policy or kind
of adopting these
methods, without--
so adopting the best of what we
like about industrial policy,
which is this byproduct
model and all these things,
without really
getting into picking
winners and losers, sort of
this In-Q-Tell kind of mechanism
here.
And I think it might be a
little bit easier to decide what
we like about industrial
policy if we just
call it industrial
policy instead
of just avoiding market
intervention as a term
entirely.
Like if you just decided, yes,
it's a market intervention,
and yes, we're doing
industrial policy,
but we want to do this
kind of market intervention
and this kind of
industrial policy,
instead of kind of masking
it with ambiguous terms,
things might get
a little easier.
And then third, I think
the call for things
is a nice way to
get around this.
So I think there's
a lot of examples
about the government putting
out calls and initiations.
And even DARPA
kind of does this,
where they initiate calls.
They say, we'd
like to do research
in this particular
area, or we'd like
to solve this
particular problem.
And it's not a way to pick
these winners and losers
and decide who does it.
But like, the person who comes
up with the best proposal
and can prove that
they can meet these
staged deadlines
will win in the end.
And it's a pretty
tried and true method
you see in things like that.
But it's just like, are we
giving room for policymakers
to make these same
judgments and put out
these calls for advancements
in R&D funding and all
these other things, with
these staged metrics.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So Chris, do you
want to give us some closing
thoughts on Glenn Fong's work?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I guess the general
theme that we've
been talking about is that
industrial policy in the US
is kind of obscured or
hidden behind these programs,
by the DOD.
And they're only manifested
when innovations are really
pushed towards that
explicit competitiveness.
And he claims that
increasing US capacity
to undertake these
programs is directly
relevant to economic
competitiveness.
Which is interesting,
because this
is kind of in direct
contrast to what
we've been talking about in
some of the past lectures,
that there's this post-war
paradigm, that they're
focusing government
R&D to basic research.
Or I believe he calls
it like mission agency.
So I think this is a
pretty interesting reading.
And also, I guess,
a side point was
that, one thing that came up
for me was this kind of conflict
between a focus on
economic competitiveness
and more I guess social
impacts or ramifications that
could result. Like he mentions
a couple of times that,
like welfare policies and
stuff aren't considered
economic competitiveness.
And using those as metrics
isn't exactly a good way
to look at competitiveness.
And I thought that was a
really interesting way to kind
of segregate, I
guess, the impact
of these kind of programs.
And obviously, they're
two very different things.
And DOD probably has
to stay out of it.
And just like we've
been mentioning,
can't really pick
winners or losers.
But yeah, I thought that
was another interesting kind
of subtext theme.